لأنني لا أستطيع مع هذا التاريخ
وفقًا لقوانين ولاية
محكمة [الموسيقى]، يمكنك رؤية وسماع
اللحظة الدقيقة التي رفض فيها القاضي R والكفالة
وبدأ في الحكم عليه بالسجن ولكن قبل أن
يتمكن القاضي من إنهاء R و  يندفع
نحوها ويقفز فوق المقعد
ويهاجمها، يمكنك رؤية القاضي يسقط
على الأرض
ويقفز حراس المحكمة الجزئية لمحاولة إيقاف RIT، ويظهر
المارشال وهم يكافحون لاحتوائه
لبضع ثوان قبل أن
ينتهي الفيديو في بيان للقناة  13
تقول محكمة مقاطعة لاس فيغاس إن القاضي H
قد تعرض لبعض الإصابات ويتم
مراقبته في الوقت الحالي، وتقول
محكمة المقاطعة إن مشير المحكمة تم
نقله إلى المستشفى بعد
تعرضه لبعض الإصابات، وهو في
حالة مستقرة، ثم يستمر البيان
ليقول اقتباسًا نشيد به  الأعمال البطولية التي قام بها
موظفوها المكلفون بإنفاذ القانون وجميع الآخرين
الذين أخضعوا المدعى عليه،
تظل المحكمة ملتزمة
بمحكمة وقاعات محكمة آمنة ومأمونة، ونحن
نراجع جميع البروتوكولات وسنفعل
كل ما هو ضروري لحماية
القضاء والجمهور وموظفونا
الآن يحكمون.  كان لديه جدول أعمال كامل للمحكمة
يوم الأربعاء ولكن بعد الحادث، قام
المارشالات بإخلاء قاعة المحكمة
لبقية اليوم، وقد مثل الآن أمام المحكمة
صباح الخميس في الساعة 9:00
أمام قاض جنائي مختلف،
ويواجه رين الآن اتهامات جديدة ناجمة عن
حادث اليوم في  المحكمة التي تشمل
تهمة جناية واحدة بالبطارية على
شخص محمي مما يؤدي إلى
ضرر جسدي كبير وثلاث
شحنات أخرى خاطئة للبطارية الصغيرة